so the Super Bowl happened and one of my
traditions that I do every year besides
actually paying attention to the game is
that I try to review at least one of the
big trailers that premiered during the
commercials because let's face it for us
people who aren't like super into sports
the commercials are the best part of the
Super Bowl and this year the Jurassic
world trailer stood out to me as the one
that was the most meaty had the most new
stuff to talk about so let's do just
that I am NOT just a big fan of Jurassic
Park Jurassic Park is part of my
childhood I grew up watching these
movies I loved the first one and I'm
actually one of the rare few people who
really enjoys the lost world the last 15
minutes kind of feel like a completely
different movie but everything up until
then I really enjoy jp3 though not a fan
they've been talking about Jurassic Park
for for a very long time so it's nice to
see some more footage I did enjoy the
first trailer it did get me pumped this
one has a lot of stuff to like about it
as well and an equal amount of things
that kind of make me take a step back
now it's so easy nowadays to get so
excited about all these big movies and
be like yeah oh my gosh I can't wait
it's gonna be incredible oh my gosh and
have no substance to my video whatsoever
and yet I have to be honest there are
aspects of this trailer that made me a
little skeptical now I think a lot of it
actually has to do with the editing
which isn't even necessarily something
to worry about because the movie is
gonna be edited completely differently
and I know it's so expensive to get any
footage shown during the Superbowl so
they probably were trying to cram as
much in there as possible so from the
gist of this trailer what I get is that
the movie is basically about a lot of
very smart people who decided to ignore
the previous three times the dinosaurs
killed a whole bunch of people to ignore
Iain Malcolm's warnings and all the
horrible things that have happened
before they create a hybrid dinosaur and
then it gets loose and it's angry and
they have to defeat it and Chris Pratt
who trains Raptors in this movie says we
got to go at him with everything we've
got you get a shot of him and a
motorcycle and Raptors signifying a
battle between Chris Pratt Raptors and
the giant hybrid dinosaur that's evil
and wants to kill and eat like a normal
dinosaur so he's not actually a bad
diner story's just an animal which is
exactly what the previous three films
were trying to say I just feel like
that's a plot that could have been
written
in cran things about the trailer I loved
it looks really swiftly directed Chris
Pratt Bryce Dallas Howard the special
effects I think looked a little bit
better than the first one it looked like
they had a couple really good
animatronic creatures as well which is
what I'm really hoping there's a lot of
a lot of people are really up in arms
about the training Raptors thing I'm not
too worried about that they're doing
something different there doing
something original kudos to them for
that we've had scary Raptors three times
already so let's see how they handle
this but honestly the thing that worries
me the most about this movie I haven't
really seen anyone else Express I feel
like the movie looks absurdly bright I'm
all for digital clarity I love me some
blu-rays I examine that stuff I get
blu-rays and I actually look for film
grain I look for cracks in the negatives
I look for hairs that show up I look for
that stuff and so I'm fine with that
it's just the movie itself looks almost
family friendly in regards to how bright
it looks my best example is Indiana
Jones and the Kingdom of the Crystal
Skull now this movie was shot on film
because Spielberg is all for film but
the movie itself a lot of people said
looked fake it looked like a soundstage
it looked way too bright it looked just
way too vivid and colorful and too cgi
esque
and that was for a movie that was shot
on film and Spielberg is a champion of
film and obviously he's made a lot of
films that are very gritty in that way
that they look you know really heavy
darks and really great contrast of
colors Indiana Jones for was just so
bright and vivid and I'm feeling the
same when I look at the Jurassic world
trailer it just looks family-friendly
almost it doesn't look as gritty and as
defined as the previous Jurassic Park
films and that's kind of something
that's worrying me and that's just my
stupid nitpicky film lover brain and
probably no one else but that's just me
all-in-all I am immensely excited to see
this movie and I actually don't think
it's gonna be bad I actually think it's
gonna be really good
there's just aspects of the way this
trailer was edited and crafted and some
of the ways the shots look and some of
the kind of childish story ideas that
make me take a step back because I'm
reviewing the trailer not the movie so
keep that in mind and I also can't just
sit here and say I loved every humungous
trailer like a gigantic fanboy because
I'm not I am very skeptical about this
and I hope that it's good what are your
guys thoughts on the Superbowl trailer
for Jurassic world and any other
trailers it aired yesterday also
thank you so much for all of the immense
love on the Toonami video that i posted
yesterday I have never in my life had
more fun making a video I've also never
been more proud of a video I can't
believe that I got Steve bloom to voice
the intro and interview him in the video
and Christopher Sabbath as Vegeta to do
my outro and interview him as well I am
my mind I was just crying like tears
really I was just I can't even speak I
was exploding with joy and I thank you
so much for the love and I really hope
you guys who haven't checked out the
video do because I worked very very hard
on it and I couldn't have done it with
some awesome help from a lot of you guys
as well so thank you so much and I also
want to let you guys know that my
promotion with shutterstock.com is still
running a lot of people have asked me
about this it's still running I have a
lot of subscribers who are independent
filmmakers and I know because you guys
send me your short films every day and
ask for my advice on them
shutterstock.com is a very good resource
for independent filmmakers or for people
who are working in the commercial
business who wants stock footage or
stock images and you can use them
legally and through me if you go to
shutterstock.com right now and enter the
promo code Chris one one five you can
get 20% off your membership to
shutterstock.com and that is through me
my gift to you guys they wanted me to
let you guys know about that it's a
great resource for independent
filmmakers or anyone who can't get shots
of LA or New York or amazing helicopter
footage your really awesome stuff like
that so definitely check that out thank
you so much as always for watching guys
I'm very very grateful thank you very
much and I really hope you check out
that Toonami video because I'm very
proud of it as always guys thank you
very much and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes